good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast happy Tuesday it is a very
happy Tuesday indeed because if you are
not watching you are listening to this
podcast thank you so much for being here
but you might not be able to see that
Jax and Claude are together again I am
in Florida so exciting such a shock to
the system I'm sure people who are
watching are just as shocked as I was as
you as I was when you came in last night
we were having dinner Claudia vlogged
the whole thing she planned this
surprise yesterday morning she woke up
and she said I think I'll see my
nibblings today I did say that and after
the toast she flew down to Florida she
vlogged like the planning and all of the
behind the scenes things that she had to
do I had zero clue and I was dining with
the Shapiro's last night at their house
when the door opened and instead of a
murderer it was lettered it was instead
of a murderer it was a sleigh it was La
Turtle
yes we won't get too much of it away I
did Vlog the whole experience for our
patreon you know some of the reasons
reasoning why I came down here you know
I don't know if anyone noticed I didn't
post a lot of Instagram stories
yesterday I was like kind of Silent on
the gram and people were probably like
oh my God I oh one thing about me I
always have like five or ten stories up
yeah not you me oh no like you like you
said sometimes have no stories like
that's very uncommon for me rarely these
days I've been extremely active excuse
so much of myself to the gram but if you
had no story people wouldn't be like oh
my God oh my God she's surprising her
sister right yeah so I am so happy to be
here I'll be here you know till the end
of time I have no return flight booked
I'm just here being returnedia and I'm
very very
um blessed very excited to be with my
family and to do a great week of
episodes with the flamingos the
flamingos finally get their day in the
sun with Jax with Bryce with stress with
roldini with k lordia with levitson the
whole family I'm so happy to be here
like really it's been long it's been a
long time December December was last
time you were here beginning of December
right yeah and I guess that was last
time I saw you because I haven't come to
New York come to New York since but you
know we'll get into later you know I'm
I'm making plans
I'm making plans too but you know
January New Year like you try and like
hunker down where you are you know
you're not just like trying to run away
yeah but now that it's February I'm
ready
um also Jackie and I are kind of looking
like Sporty Spice like cool girl today
we are wearing our Spritz hats which I
feel like I didn't realize we didn't
sell them because Ben wears them
literally every day but we had never uh
put them up for sale until today so at
noon which I feel like if you're
listening to this it's already noon
spritzociety.com Jackie's wearing like a
hunter green a super cool green I would
say like it's it's kind of the green
that my wedding color was for my
bridesmaid so that's like an emerald
green yeah emeralds Emerald City the
front says Spritz society and the back
says pickleball classic with a little
pickleball on the side because we love
pickleball and it's just like a Cool
vibe and mine is like a white with a
tangerine embroidery
it says estimated 2029 they're really
cool I've been wears them all the time
is that not what EST stands for
established
oh my God like obviously I'm so dumb we
have to cut that out that's literally a
matter like I guess technically it could
be estimated no because it's not like an
estimation is like an about you know but
maybe they're just saying like about
2021 it's what we're about no but like
it was 22. I appreciate you trying to
like you know undo some of the damage I
just did to my reputation
um
but yeah established 2021
spritzociety.com get your hats I've been
loving wearing it like backwards hats
that's so crazy I just feel like cool
girls that can rock hats backwards you
know what I mean and that's you
um nothing if not the coolest girl on
the planet
now I want to talk to you about
something I don't know if I brought this
up the last time I was here but every
time we podcast together I sit in this
chair
and I stare directly at a 20 bill that's
like sitting on the table and I just
want to know one how the 20 bill got
there and how you have not like I cannot
leave a quarter lying around without
throwing it in my pocket like 20 I think
there actually might be two I think it's
40 40 yeah what was it I feel like
I have no idea I have an idea of what it
might be from like when we were building
the studio like the wallpaper.com people
come like help and maybe we had cash out
to tip them and like that was leftover
cash maybe but like I feel like I've
walked past it enough times like it's
mine now like I want to take it if you
took it I wouldn't like notice it has
not moved it hasn't been touched it's
literally right behind the camera that's
psychotic no but it's like you know when
you see something every day you don't
even notice it anymore like I literally
don't even notice it it's like if I were
like looking for 20 in my house like I
wouldn't even I wouldn't even realize
that many dollars would be here so like
twenty dollars from my show it was
eighty dollars
um so like could I take it
well now that you've asked no but if you
had stolen it now maybe we'll get
ourselves some lunch on the business
yeah let's do a vlog how to spend we can
get these forty dollars in this economy
it's like three eggs literally I don't
think that forty dollars you know since
it's been sitting here since you moved
into your house it's literally lost
value I should have spent it when I put
it down a hundred percent
yeah
um okay I'm glad we got that out of the
way I feel like I'm oh wait like if
you're watching on YouTube I'm never
looking at the camera I'm looking behind
it at the forty dollars
it is so weird that it's up here
um so I'm looking at everything like
there's a roll of toilet paper no I I
hate to be negative I know you don't
like the state of my studio but it's
better than last time yeah it works for
me like because it's all just like crap
that I need
and there's no organizing the crap okay
let's talk about this okay sweater
that's literally for a child it's so
small it's a crop sweater it's a crop
sweater it's sitting right why is it
here and there's a little bit of a stain
makeup looks like um
maybe like an iced tea the reason it's
sitting on a pile of merch over there
and the reason that it's here is because
I wore it on the show and then I
continue to do my job and take some
pictures in merch so I took it off
swapped it for some merch and then went
downstairs in my merch got it okay well
that's another answer it I I'm not like
running to bring it back to oh that's
Merchant nevermind this is merch that
never made the cut I think it's for the
best it's like it's not that cute it's
whatever sauce
um there's just like a lot of stuff in
here
my holiday lights my printer my printer
paper I've got some Spritz I've got a
ton of cords because this is a studio
you know the cords don't bother me
because that's like chords like we're
women at work we're recordia
mccordia
um I guess I could get like some drawers
like should that be like our activity
for the week to get this place in
Tip-Top shape yeah
you don't sound excited just cause like
I know where everything is everything's
just like out I have this like cute it's
weird because I have this bench thing so
I just put everything on the bench and
like listen I'm not gonna come in here
and tell you this is not my studio and
I've been like I you know I I get my
work to you on time kill it you kill it
every Studio the files come through
strong strong it's like the way that it
is works works for your girl so you know
what I'll shut the [__] up I'll think
I'll look online for a little like
storage system maybe yeah I just thought
it could be like a fun activity you know
two sisters spending time together with
forty dollars going in The Container
Store yeah oh you know what forty
dollars we'll get you at The Container
Store one hanger yeah The Container
Store is so pricey but it's such a a
paradise elevated experience it is my
local Container Store actually went out
of business that was really tough
tough time for the community I'm sorry
you had to experience that it's okay are
you gonna wear this hat the whole time
no I'm hot no like we're sitting under
these bright lights
I hate taking my hat off I think I'll
leave it on backwards do I look cool at
all it's a little like pull it down a
little bit but then you're gonna be on
your now it's weird because your part is
like through the okay what about this
okay
it's just like support society.com you
guys the hats are super cool yeah I
actually feel like I'm gonna be wearing
a hat a lot while I'm down here the
weather is truly Georgina
um you know I had doubts about you
moving to Florida on like this humidity
and when you moved in the summer and
when I came down I was like I was so
right about this place this [__] is
crazy I could never ever and it's such
delightful weather I was wrong that
there really is a breeze it's warm but
it's not
unbearable and it's not humid no and
this time of year there are days that
are like cold yeah so that's nice it's
nice I'm so happy to be here I had such
a great time last night so you know what
I started doing
um just keep everyone abreast on the
content I started watching Ginny in
Georgia I heard your TV was on like
really late okay like 11 30 I turned it
off I was like gonna text you like but I
didn't want you to think I was like
trying to tell you to turn it off but I
just wanted to text you and be like
that's crazy that you're watching TV so
late uh if you had texted me I would
have been like oh my God I'm again
getting kicked out
that's why I didn't text you but like
I
was surprised that you watched TV late I
feel like you don't do that okay late it
was 11 30. you're like granny yeah if
you go to sleep earlier than me I have a
hard time sleeping like when I'm not in
my own house so like I have to stay up
late to make myself really tired so I
don't lay there and I still laid there
for 30 minutes I laid for a while last
night too I guess just all the
excitement I don't actually think
there's a worse experience like a worse
part of Being Human than being like
awake at night not being able to sleep
having a lot on your mind going to the
Doomsday like you know what if everyone
I love dies like it is literally the
worst part of being alive and you can't
convince me otherwise yeah especially
when like then it's getting later I had
to wake up a little earlier today yeah
you're like if I fall asleep hours are
taking my I'm gonna get six hours of
sleep and then you're like okay now it's
five and a half it's literally the worst
thing ever but I was still so happy to
be here I slept next to Harry you know
who's in my room his and eyes rooms are
right next to each other so I felt like
at peace and I maybe I couldn't sleep
because I felt protective I'm like I'm
technically the first line of defense
events in this house you know you and
Theo me and Theo and let's be real in a
crisis Theo's absolutely useless his
hearing has gone his hearing is gone
he's so lazy he's out of shape but Bryce
that's where Bryce steps up you can't
move a muscle yeah without
you like an attention [__] he's so cute
that's Trice the boys had a great
morning this morning Jackie just
happened to have Theo's Bruno's grooming
appointment today so you know Theo had
to like
I'll take one too yeah and he took the
first appointment like like a true older
brother would and he looks great he got
his anal glands expressed he's feeling
really really good and strong this is a
good start to his week it is and it's
like this is gonna be a bright a strong
Bryce and Stripes week Bryce isn't here
because he is getting groomed right now
but then they'll be on the show all week
because they like being in studio with
us when we're together and they're gonna
be looking their best and that's really
like you love to see that for them yeah
if we can't they can they might as well
yeah we're looking great because we have
our new hats that we'll wear to the
party tonight I was gonna ask if you
were gonna wear your hat to the party
tonight of course what else would I wear
that is like oh by the way your Mike
flag is upside down
um engagement oh speaking of things we
[__] up oh yeah let's correct issue a
correction from yesterday I'll let
Jackie speak because it was her [__] up
Justin baldoni is playing Ryle right and
apparently it's pronounced Riley
said who Colleen like when she was in
her Tick Tock she's like
to me it's rile r-y-l-e first of all
better than I I couldn't watch that Tick
Tock bad name did you watch the whole
Tick Tock no I skipped um because the
first like two minutes were like she
bought a house for her mom I'm so happy
for her but like I don't care yeah so I
skipped two like where um the captions
said Blake Lively you know oh okay
um so he's playing Ryle which is even
worse idea at least by saying it was
Atlas like we were giving it we were
making it sound better because like just
based on that picture that they kept
using like he looks more like an atlas
not like a Riley yeah and his name I'm
sorry cannot be Riley like agreed not
that's not an to spell Riley r-y-l-e is
not a name no it's Ryle if it was Riley
she would have spelled it like two e's
or r-i-l-e-y it's rile like Kyle like
Kyle like it's right and then oh um
the other thing was about broccoli is
the third string right Jimmy Garoppolo I
thought he was like our Star Quarterback
he was already number two I guess number
one some guy who obviously he could be
some guy I hadn't heard his name I in
all I mean I don't watch that much
football really and
I get my information from like whatever
I see in that moment on TV and like what
pop culture Zach Weiner and Zach Shapiro
are saying but never once was it
mentioned that there was a third guy a
hundred percent so like literally how
would I know that no clue but we were
just like spewing lies yesterday on the
show like when I think of the 49ers like
everyone has their quarterback that like
you know and it's Jimmy Garoppolo that's
what I thought but it's not I need to
know
but you know what that just makes what
the 49ers did this season that much more
of an accomplishment because not only
were they not on their first string
quarterback they weren't even on their
second string so you know what they
could be sad that to make it to the
Super Bowl because they could be proud
of the work that they did with some
third string nobody okay who's now a
star by the way okay just want to say it
says first Jimmy Garoppolo second Brock
Purdy on this depth chart from the
49ers.com
it sounds like everyone knows me an
apology well here's the other question
it's like now that this season is over
and Josh Johnson is number three you
guys Jackie what are you talking about
now that the season is over and
everyone's gonna you know take some time
off and heal when they get back to the
field for spring training who's the
quarterback I think that they're gonna
have to Duke it out yeah maybe someone
gets traded like maybe the 49ers realize
they have like two valuable players like
they could switch they can't even have
zero though because that's what we saw
because everyone's in Jordan yeah no you
need two good quarterbacks I think that
they will each like have to get in
practice and prove who deserves to be
first string like there it should be a
meritocracy yeah no I think it is it
will be that'll be awkward for sure yeah
but it happens you know it happens all
the time 100 we're like the older guy
has to take a back seat and how does
that make him feel is this still what he
wants to do
Maybe not maybe not
um and I feel like today you know I saw
we got a lot of feedback from
yesterday's episode mostly that we uh
were wrong about the casting of rile but
um from a lot of straight males I think
they really kind of connected with our
content and I think today we might have
some straight males listening so to them
I say sup dude uh Cowabunga and I'll see
you uh out in the slopes yeah and I
would say also I don't know if today's
episode's gonna be for you like it's
very Back to Basics here I think all
five stories are about females no
actually actually no we do have an NFL
adjacent story love that so you should
stick around and you should stick around
I think we might surprise you straight
boys I think that you'll be shocked at
what you see here and how much you're
enjoying it and how truly funny women
can be I think it'll be surprising yeah
I'm excited for you guys to go on this
journey and feel free to make yourselves
known leave a comment on YouTube where
you from what do you do how'd you get
here always curious about our straight
male toasters yeah I feel like they're
all just like a husbands who have to
listen in the car and now maybe they'll
listen like a little less begrudgingly
less begrudgingly yeah that's what I
think well that means we're just helping
toasters in need yeah bring toasters
together like I like it would be amazing
if there was a podcast that Zach and I
both loved and like we would like sit
and listen and crack up yeah I feel
crack up I feel like when it when
they're like maybe it'll be new heights
when there are couples who like love
podcasts it's always like the wife loves
the toast and the guy loves PMT you know
oh what's that one Sam part of my take
but yeah where are you getting this
information just like from what I see on
social media like it's like I do believe
like in a lot of like we are the female
equivalent of PMT like a Daily Show oh
okay I think that's like what the vibe
is out there I've never listened to PMT
I'm sure they're great but I think
that's like who we are in the landscape
of podcasting I'm pretty sure I've never
thought about that well I've thought
like if they're you know who are we the
female equivalent because you really
obviously new heights but they're weekly
and but they're Brethren their Brethren
but they are weekly and like I mean in
the offseason they'll go to daily I love
that but when you really think about
podcasting it's the modern radio and
people weirdly podcasts are a weekly
thing but radio is a daily thing like
you have a Daily Show so I think the I I
think I'm right about like the female
equipment because it's like our
entertainment is their Sports yeah it's
every day yeah but it's just one main
host no no it's a is it Brethren no it's
not Brethren but it's the guys you know
them the guys I know the one the
mustache yeah big cat big cat yeah you
know he's a father and a mother I know
and I'm not sure about the other guy but
like I feel like like I feel like
there's another guy and it's not KFC no
no no
um I think he like kind of looks like
KFC
I really have no idea but
um wishing him the best yeah they're
they're tops
their tops like top of the chart okay
oh my God no you know tops is an
adjective
where I come in the book I was just
reading like they were like this house
is hot she was like why are you happy
Marjorie this house is TOPS oh your
husband like yeah where I come from tops
is a noun I mean I guess where I come
from it could also be an adjective no
it's like you're a top it's a noun yeah
yeah okay
but that's the thing about language
constantly changing yeah yeah
um so I feel
I feel like it's time I'm looking at the
clock the clock and it's like it's
totally time what is the clock saying
the clock's saying it's time to Jive in
to to what the past size sorry is that
you need to know yet you this episode of
the toast is supported by State Farm the
State Farm personal price plan helps you
create a plan that gives you options so
you get an affordable price and it comes
with lots of benefits like the coverage
you want a policy that helps cover
what's important to you and an
affordable price just for you because
after all life is just better when you
can personalize your experiences I feel
like we're constantly talking about
personalization here on the show comedy
is personal poetry is personal and you
know what else is Insurance because we
all have different needs and being able
to make a really personalized price plan
from State Farm is so easy because you
know insurance is not one size fits all
personalization means you have the power
to choose what you want to include and
lead out what you don't and it just
feels better that way because shouldn't
because Insurance should work like that
that's what State Farm personal price
plan is all about you can choose to
include coverage options like bundling
your home and auto policies and that
means you'll get the coverage you want
at an affordable price that's made just
for you in the end you'll have a policy
that gives you what you want and what's
better than that what's better than
getting what you want uh literally
nothing in this world world nothing in
this world compares to just like having
things catered to you being the way that
you need them to be because everyone is
different no and you know the world
revolves around me but the world also
revolves around you yeah everyone's
world revolves around themselves and
State Farm understands that and I've
always wanted to say this like a good
neighbor State Farm is there cut about
that call or go to statefarm.com today
to create your State Farm personal price
plan prices vary by state an option
selected by customer availability and
eligibility may vary again that's call
or go to statefarm.com today to create
your State Farm personal price plan
today's episode is also brought to you
and sponsored by betterhelp when you're
at your best you can do great things but
sometimes life gets you bogged down and
you may feel overwhelmed or like you're
not showing up in the way that you want
to working with a therapist can help you
get closer to the best version of you
because when you feel empowered you're
more prepared to take on everything life
throws at you if you've been thinking
about giving therapy a try or it's
something you've wanted to do but you
don't really know where to start check
out betterhelp it's a really accessible
and affordable way of getting therapy
it's a great option it's convenient it's
flexible affordable and done entirely
online what I really like about
betterhelp is you know once you get
connected with a licensed therapist you
can change really easily because you
know not everyone is going to connect
with everyone and I find that like a lot
of people who have great success with
therapy had to change you know one or
two times before they found the right
therapist and I'd better help makes that
really easy
um how it works is you'll fill out a
brief questionnaire and you'll get
matched with a licensed therapist and
you can switch therapists anytime for no
additional charge so if you want to live
a more empowered life therapy can get
you there visit betterhelp.com toast to
get 10 off your first month today that's
betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com slash toast betterhelp.com
t-o-a-s-t start taking care of your
brain your mental health and you today
it's never ever too late to start
looking out for number one and that's
you and better help is a great place to
do that betterhelp.com toast so true so
while you were doing that I was doing a
little research on part of my take okay
and the name of big cats co-host is PFT
commenter
yeah he has long hair okay but like
that's why we probably couldn't blame
him there's only so many acronyms he's
PFT commenter and his real name is Eric
sollenberger right that's why we didn't
know his name because he don't have a
name and what I also found to be
interesting was I went to the sports
category to see what where PFT number
one PMT ranks it's number two today
because New Heights is number one it all
comes back to the Kelsey Brethren then
everyone is feeling the same way that
we're feeling about brother V brother
and they want to hear what the Kelsey
Brethren have to say about it have you
seen the viral photo of their mom what
she'll be wearing to the Super Bowl
where it is a custom Jersey half Eagles
half Chiefs Queen We Love
um we love an equally supportive Queen
yeah I mean she must be really torn like
no not torn Travis Kelsey was asked in
the um press conference after the game
like you know this is huge like what are
you feeling he was like I just know this
is No One's Gonna have more fun at the
Super Bowl than my mom oh of course she
can't lose
she can't lose
but it's just it's literally so crazy no
it's the craziest thing it's she's a
piece like she doesn't have the best
seat in the house shut it down I need
whoever's sponsoring the Super Bowl I
need like apple music to get this woman
like a box on the field no she needs a
50-yard line first row and then I think
like a butler if then at halftime she
goes to the other side to support the
other son that's really good somebody
just needs to make sure she's like taken
care of to the highest degree and that
like maybe she sits like at the 50-yard
line and then at the
End Zone and then at the 50 yards she'll
work around Each corner like a clock
12 o'clock three o'clock six o'clock
night I think we need a channel that's
like just
camera on her we actually you know if I
worked in marketing right now and I was
working on the Super Bowl like I would
try and get to her because a million
eyes on her I have to get her on the
toes I know and she obviously respects
podcasting her sons yeah maybe she like
is a toaster and she was like these
sisters do it like why not you oh my god
were we the inspiration for New Heights
when did New Heights come out it
definitely feels relatively new or maybe
what people are only caring about it in
the last couple of months because the
possibility of Two Brothers being in the
Super Bowl was like a potential thing so
crazy
um and also there's a clip from they
also Jackie they've they vodcast too
and there's a clip of the pot like a
moment on the podcast that's going crazy
viral because the other brother Jason
has kids and the daughter like ran into
the podcast and sat on the dad's lap and
she's like hi Uncle Trev or whatever
what what's Travis Travis that's his
name yeah catching Kelsey Travis Kelsey
I really think his first name is
catching
um she's like hi Uncle chathy and Travis
Kelsey's like so hot and he's like hey
baby girl how you doing and like that
moment of him like being like hey baby
girl there's like a million views on
this video he looks so hot
um so it's just like it's even more
oppressed for the podcast this is
honestly podcast press a podcast I could
only dream of you could only dream of I
think you and I should join the WNBA and
you know what if we want to be even more
irrelevant than we are now that's what
we should do justice for the NBA WNBA
yeah but like everyone wants Justice for
the WNBA but nobody wants to watch and
support like no one even wants to like
just turn the channel on and walk out of
the room it's so true I feel like people
are always talking about like the
imbalance in sports I mean look at the
WNBA and the people who say that have
never once bought a ticket a t-shirt a
subscription couldn't be caught dead
watching like where do you even watch
such such an important question I know
that the the Liberty I think that's the
that might be the D-League men's team
not the WNBA I think they're in Liberty
um I know they play at MSG but it's like
you know only a couple of rows people in
the middle of the day it ain't right
it's really so sad but like it's
we all know what's wrong and we're all
actively not helping no but it's like
you can't force people to care about
things that they don't care about no I
know and this is meant to be
entertainment like
I don't like you get to choose what you
are entertained by no I know are there
any sports well outside of the other
women's are more popular gymnastics but
that's the Olympics okay but even like
you know there are National level
college and and women's is way too much
popular than men yeah
hmm
um I feel like for a while soccer you
could say in this country because women
were so much better and they still are
but even like you know 30 years ago like
Mia ham right you know I don't know who
was doing that on the men's team in the
U.S can I tell you the story so random
that you brought up me a ham so when we
were in Belize we were out to dinner and
we were playing this game where like a
person would leave the table and we'd
all come up with a celebrity
um like we choose a celebrity and then
they come back and like ask a million
questions until they figured out what
celebrity we were talking about and we
tried to do like really random people
like no one would choose like Kyle
Richards for me they chose like someone
I think somebody did like Putin like so
Random so for somebody we chose me a ham
um not only did the person who it was
not know who Mia ham was nobody at the
table knew either like when we were all
like coming up it was just me and Becca
and we were like you guys don't know Mia
ham that's disgraceful who was leaving
like I guess nobody knew but nobody knew
Margo didn't know I don't think Margo
knew she's a little young yeah I was
just like it's Mia ham not like LeBron
James like
she's not LeBron James but she's like
Billie Jean no she's like Nancy Kerrigan
you know okay but like Nancy Kerrigan
might have been unknown if she didn't
get her knees bashed in yeah but like
Mia ham might have been unknown if she
wasn't an amazing like everyone has
their story everyone has their thing oh
my God that was like literally like girl
boss Gaslight repeat like what that's
not what we're saying no you're saying
she like like me and him is known for
being the goat and I'm trying to think
of somebody else who's known for being
the goat Nancy character is known for
getting her knees bashed in in a
goat-like way literally
like someone a female who's known for
being the goat like any of the Billie
Jean figure skaters that were like
Michelle Kwan yeah
yeah Billie Jean King is just like I
barely know who that is no and Billie
Jean King I think is known more for like
her like she's obviously an amazing
tennis player but I think she's also
known more for like the stride she made
for women and like the gay community
more than like she's still like an
amazing if if I was like someone chose
Billie Jean King for me like maybe on my
thousandth question I would have got I I
would never have guessed Billy jacking
do you want to play that game right now
sure okay let me think of someone so
[__] random it's hard because
like I just want to choose the Kelsey
Brothers you wanted to so do I
okay I got one okay am I a man or a
woman no sorry it's only yes or no
questions am I a woman no my man yes am
I an athlete no but I could be
am I an actor no
am I a singer no
am I a celebrity yes my politician no
uh
am I reality star no
am I an influencer no
am I employed yes
Elon Musk no I'm trying to think of
someone random for you not if I wanted
to guess who would Jack be Jackie's
first guess I would have done the Elon
Musk and my businessman yes
am I successful yes am I like one of the
ones
adjacent
yeah
um
am I liked by the hosts of the toast
I don't think they care am I disgust by
the hosts of the toast maybe once a year
do I own a company am I a CEO kind of
because
like no you're not but you're like
you're like at the top of what you do
you know uh do I you're like getting
close I can feel it yeah do I it's like
I'm the top of what I do do I do TED
Talks
I don't think so am I in social media no
who the [__] am I
um
some of I'm in business
yeah like you have a job
oh God
um am I Ben no it's a celebrity
uh oh I'm a celebrity with a job man
yeah
I feel like it's like so easy now
like go back to some of the earlier
questions because you asked a question
and I said no but like
you were close because it was like a
sports job A-Rod no
and my former Sports no
and my former am I am I famous for just
business my business
um am I Jeff Bezos no my Bill Gates no
am I like I said you're not far like
you're not am I American yes
am I New York based I have no [__]
idea
I feel like you're circling the drain
like
like how so your it sounds like kind of
like a losery businessman
like I actually thought I didn't choose
random enough like you would get it so
quick
and I'm not discussed by the host of the
toast really like maybe once a year
um
like I'm not telling you until you get
up this is so ask our questions okay
um
so do I did I create my business no am I
alive yes so I'm the CEO of a business
someone else created yes
and CEO was like a loose term
hmm I'm head of yes
come on I literally don't know uh Bob
Iger no
but like you're getting closer the other
guy who just got fired
um Ted sarandos no
you're moving far further away okay back
to Disney bye-bye girl no back before
that
before about biker I was the c i I am
the CEO of a company I did not create
um but like not really so yeah if I told
you his title it would give it away
garyvee no
this game is hard it is
okay I'll give you a clue okay thank you
clock okay I literally said his name
yesterday randomly on the toast oh my
God
that like really doesn't help me okay I
should just tell you because like I'm
sure the listeners want to kill I'm sure
the listeners are baffled I feel like
people might might have gotten it am I
telling you give me one more clue okay
so his job is like kind of
um
like polarizing in the sense of like a
lot of people [__] hate him and think
he's like bad at his job but it's just
because they're like fanatics
how is it not Elon
it does sound like I'm describing Elon
but I'm not
can be gratitude no I should have chose
Greta you should yeah
um okay I give up okay you have one more
clue sure okay Dave Portnoy is like
biggest anime
excuse me
no Roger Goodell oh my God I would have
never gotten that did you ask me is he
an athlete and I have to say no but like
I wish you said does he work in sports
Claudia I I would have never gotten that
in my life is it a fun game yeah I just
wasn't I was really thinking in the
business sector it's a great dinner
party game feel free to take that with
you to your next dinner party and Roger
Goodell is a good one yeah Superman
not us being like so bar stool today so
bar stool barstoolia
okay first story Switching gears the
Jonas Brothers get a star on the
Hollywood Walk of Fame they wrap up
their ceremony with an album
announcement their upcoming record the
album arrives May 5th the Jonas Brothers
appeared in La earlier yesterday to
receive a star in the Hollywood Walk of
Fame with crowds of fans gathered to
celebrate the honor nearly two decades
into their career The Sibling Trio
wanted to send them off with a gift too
saying I think we should make a quick
announcement we are excited to announce
that our new album the album will be
coming out May 5th so I just have to say
I loved like all the content we got out
of yesterday like Priyanka was there
with their baby and we had never seen
the baby and then Danielle was there
with the kids Sophie Turner was there so
if he turned into an upbring her child
yes she did not bring the kids so we
still haven't seen those kids I feel
like she's like we're never gonna see
them
um but like was anyone else confused I
thought I felt like Hollywood Walk of
Fame was like literally for like actors
oh not even actors but like
you know
people at the end of a storied career I
feel like these days it's just like a PR
no I feel like whenever I hear about
somebody getting a Hollywood Walk of
Fame storm like they didn't have one
already it's like really like a
long-term thing and I feel like the
Jonas brothers are still like in their
Prime yeah at their Peak excuse me and I
feel like you don't get it at your Peak
no hour that you shouldn't like just
that's something that you could do when
you're less busy and it's like your
legacy right
um but I just kind of feel like
it's like you know Madame Tussauds like
it's like I want one they want me let's
do it I feel like the Walk of Fame still
has like a little bit of Integrity like
Madame Tussaud has no Integrity I agree
um no I think Madame too so it's still
cool and the Walk of Fame is still cool
but like it's not like you know the Hall
of Fame no but the thing is with Madame
tusso like peoples come in and out so
you can be really hot and like very
famous and then like years later fit
into relevancy and they need to go to a
warehouse you go to a warehouse they
bring in new people it's like a it's
like a rotating door but the Walk of
Fame is like there's only so much real
estate there's a lot of sidewalks like
yeah you but like technically we could
go on forever technically you could but
like it's it lives forever yeah so it's
more permanent and that's why I feel
like they wait till like someone's
really year after year after year after
year been like super super famous and I
don't know they're just so young like
they're in their 30s I don't know yeah
no way it was definitely surprising but
I feel like it was
it's like a PR thing at this point yeah
and it was a gorgeous Morgan Stewart was
there it was like a really celeb I also
always find it interesting who the
celebrities asked to come like that's
how you know who like their actual
friends in Hollywood are not just like
media friends like Andy Cohen of course
had John Mayer like I always find it
really interesting
the McGraw's
their family I think that was a yeah I
didn't see anyone else of note but I
just I find that interesting like the
Celeb friendships and who they have like
speak on their behalf yeah well I think
like Mariah Carey spoke at Andy Cohen's
like Andy's had like of course Andy's
like such like a [__] yeah Andes
was like filled with celebrities yeah
all three Brethren spoke here I think I
didn't see Kevin speak but Joe spoken
Nick's spoke but I'm sure Kevin said
yeah he did I'm ready for a new Joe Bro
album I feel like it's been a long time
me too so Kevin posted a video that was
like teaser with a little bit of song
and the song was good I feel like they
released the album when they got back
together and it was really good then
they did like a couple singles that like
are not a part of the album
because like whatever happened to the
most underrated best song on the planet
what a man Gotta Do
to be totally locked up by you that was
good
um
so is that like on an album or is that
gonna be on this album you know what I
mean yeah that's a good question let me
go I just love that song yeah that is a
good song let me go to happiness begins
which shows the last album that they
released
is that was that the first album
together as a Reunion yeah so there's
only been 2018.
yeah this is like sucker yeah okay yeah
then what a man gotta do that's a good
is that a single
was that a single I think it was who's
in your head remember this but that was
for the Olympics no and a lot of what
they do is like a collab with
marshmallow before you love me oh god
oh really good songs also
um green light from sorry songland Ryan
Tedder was there speaking of of course
he was there to support he played a huge
role in their comeback yes he did he was
on their album happiness begins um does
anyone else like I feel like another
Jonas Brothers break I don't want to
like put this out in the either I
definitely feel as though another Jonas
Brothers breakup is like on the horizon
I feel like there's such weirdness and
tension especially between Joe and Nick
Joe spoke yesterday and he said
something that ensured that there won't
be like he said
I forget what it was exactly from what I
watched of something like you know we've
been doing this for 20 years and we'll
be doing it for 20 more okay I mean I
perhaps I'm just reading into it like
whenever I see people sharing you know I
went to the Jonas Brothers at a Vegas
residency I'm like always watching the
dynamic between Nick and Joe and like I
don't know if I'm just seeing stuff or
I'm looking for stuff but I feel like
there's like hatred there there's
weirdness but I think at this point
they've figured out a way to work
together where hopefully they can just
be like co-workers when they're working
and then like brothers when they're not
and not trying to like beat up each
other's butts yeah we are not everyone
can be up each other's butts no but it
is my favorite place to be right and I
can't imagine not being there not being
and being like one way when we're
working in another way when we're with
the family no me neither that would be
so [__] weird right but like for you
know millions of dollars right they'll
figure it out for millions of dollars
elect however you want me to act right
right just when it's the difference
between like literally being part of a
band that can go on a world tour and
make millions of dollars or you know
trying out my think solo again
we'll make it work yeah and then there
was like that weird thing like after the
they got back together like Nick
released a solo album that floppity flop
flop flopped
um and I think album Spaceman
yeah and I feel
I feel as though he's been cured of
wanting to go out on a solo career
because like that was like kind of
embarrassing it was like such a flop
yeah it's been Chapman I could use some
space and something like that that's
Kelsey case Musgraves
no that's you can have your space
cowboy no he's just like I could use
some space like something like that then
it wasn't like specimen it wasn't and
that's why it flopped she ever talked to
us 100 anyways it's really cute yeah I'm
excited for a new album New Era like to
see these boys and Spotlight doing their
thing and I'm glad that they used their
time off productively like many a baby
were born yeah they made an album baby
baby baby yeah it's great it's great
Mazel Tov and I just love to see Daniel
Jonas out here girly from New Jersey
like you know doing the most yeah and
keeping up with everyone like she's
slays oh she's slays and I just feel
like her and Kevin like they enjoy their
life it's like so exciting but also so
normal so grounded yeah no I think it's
got the best of both worlds honestly I
think if I could like in an ideal world
like have to trade lives with any of the
Jonas Brothers like I would probably
want Kevin's 100 he gets like you know
be in the studio with Ryan Tedder go to
the Grammys but he also lives like this
hella normal life his kids are grown he
had kids earliest so his kids are grown
now and I feel like they're just really
enjoying the comeback
I don't know I feel like they have a
nice life I agree yeah
are you ready for our next story
Julia foxes is missing critics of her
modest New York City Apartment says it
provides a sense of the normalcy from
her for her son so Julia fox went viral
on Tick Tock last week so viral she did
an apartment tour of her New York City
Apartment where she lives with her son
Valentino and it was not what you would
maybe think when you think of where does
Julia fox live right and when you think
of Julia fox live
literally also just when you think of
Julia Fox she's like this it girl
fashion girl and I think a lot of people
were shocked because you know when you
see someone in fashion you think like
fashion is Rich but
I feel like actually if you like work in
fashion and like you're not like born
into like a rich family there's actually
not a lot of money in like being a
socialite yes but I think there's two
things it's like I don't know how much
money she makes or how much money she
has but she's consciously decided to
live a modest way and that is modestly
and she said in this follow-up video
that she was posted like this is the
apartment that she brought her son home
to when she gave birth to him she gave
birth to him a year before she started
dating Kanye I do think like her
fortunes have changed a little bit Yeah
but she wants to keep a sense of
normalcy for him so the apartment is
technically a two-bedroom but she took
her her bedroom and she put her bed in
the living room so that her bedroom
could be Valentino's playroom which was
so cute and then like she shows the
apartment which has a lot of stuff in it
like New York City Apartments do and
then she shows Valentino's room which is
like a child's dream Playhouse I have to
say it actually really like it was it
was a chaotic tutorial and like her
house was messy and you know what
whatever but the way like her whole
house was like so chaotic and then her
son's bedroom was like architectural
digest it actually made me really like
her like how she like really
um doesn't care about like really
anything except the welfare and
happiness of her kid and I thought that
was like really sweet yes I thought that
was really sweet too except then when I
saw Valentino's room I was like oh he
has everything that he needs in his room
it's a little Paradise like you could
put your bedroom back in the bedroom put
your bed back in the bedroom because
like it's not like that playroom like
had that much going on and like if I'm
Valentino I'd rather play in my room
yeah plus she said that Valentino
doesn't even sleep in his room he sleeps
with her so they're both sleeping in the
living room and there's two bedrooms
yeah but I just feel like for her it's
not about what makes sense you know like
she's just like our chaotic like all
over the place girly like logic doesn't
go here no and so I really did
appreciate like how much her life
revolves her around her son and like
whatever space she does have she's gonna
maximize it for Valentino until she said
that there is mice yeah and that they're
chilling and that like she she like
leaves food for them and like their pets
she's not actively trying to exterminate
the roaches and the Rats no like
Valentino will drop crumbs and like they
know that over night there my friends
will clean it up yeah no and I'm all
about you know
protecting animals but I do think she's
hanging a little far
um and that's just for me personally not
cool yeah yeah but that's the thing that
Julie Foxx is like and I think that's I
don't know if she's doing it
intentionally but it's definitely a part
of her success it's like she's kind of
crazy
I think that's just who she is yeah
anyways so she posted another video live
from her birthday trip in the Bahamas
talking about the reaction she said um
that I know I don't know she's noted at
the time that she knew she was gonna get
roasted but she said despite
anticipating some haters she was
surprised that the negative response she
received and posted a video in response
saying quote I really wasn't expecting
my apartment tour to go so viral people
are really freaking out over it it's
really just not that deep this just
happens to be the apartment that I took
my son home from the hospital in so it's
his home it's really is Valentino's
apartment it's like a Sentimental thing
that's kind of why I'm like even though
I could probably afford a bigger place
probably because I am in New York after
all it's about having that sense of
normalcy from Valentino she added that
she hopes her son will grow up being in
touch with reality because quote I grew
up in the real world believe it or not
so I just want my son to have the same
she also said that she didn't want her
son to be eight quote [__] prick no
for sure and by the way the apartment
when you look past the crap everywhere
it's like a really nice big two bedroom
in New York City like that's still an
expensive apartment just didn't look it
because like it was just kind of like a
tornado had ran through it yeah but
still and I'm sure it's in a great part
of town like it's still an expensive
apartment and I'm sure I'm assuming she
rents it yeah I don't think people had
it took on merge with like the size of
the apartments the two bedroom in New
York it's a two bedroom in New York
she's like a big kitchen she lives in a
a neighborhood that she wants to be in
but it was just the stuff yeah there was
a lot of um stuff
ashes of friends oh yeah
there was a lot of shoe boxes in the
kitchen yeah relatable which like in New
York City you cannot keep shoe boxes
like I know you can't all want to like
for resale like it's yeah but you got to
get rid of them so true and they go for
the same amount whether you have the box
or not so much
she needs a little bit like
she's like a home organizer to come over
yeah yeah she does yeah I'm speaking of
viral pictures and she's not listening
to us no and you know what respect like
I kind of love people who don't [__]
listen to anyone I love I really like
that she does not give a [__] no one's
gonna say something that's gonna make
her change her I should go clean my
house like [__] off
um but speaking of viral tick tocks it's
worth mentioning I know you're probably
not keeping abreast on the Michaela
situation no I was going to ask you
Michaela has still not said a word okay
I have a new Theory
um and also it's kind of adjacent to our
next story which is about Jeffree Star
yes who is back at it and fans are
freaking out because he posted some
photos with quote his new NFL boyfriend
and everybody's trying to figure out who
it is yeah so he set off wild
speculation as he posted a photo of him
on a private jet with his quote NFL
boyfriend and fans are desperately
trying to identify the mystery player
even going so far as zooming in they
posted a picture of them holding hands
and they like found a little Freckle on
him oh my God they're like it's an
identifier in there it is going to find
football player years with an identifier
four six six because he's taller than
Jeffrey no Jeffrey said my six six NFL
player Oh in one of his tweets yeah but
that's what's so funny about the
Michaela thing is like so you know
Jeffrey also made a return last week he
responds to Michaela in response to
Michaela he made a video he's back
reviewing makeup and he reviewed the
telescopic mascara that set off you know
set the world on fire and everyone was
like living for it and it was all these
people who are like I hate Michaela she
needs to be held accountable and it's
like okay so you're gonna lose your and
these are the same people who like a
year ago was like Jeffree Star is
problematic so it's like you're so like
the internet is so unscrupled and
everyone's like we're against cancer
culture and you said something last week
that like resonated so deeply within my
soul
because you know we're now at the place
where it's like everyone agrees cancel
culture it's like most most people agree
cancel culture is not the vibe and it's
like it's like embarrassing if you're
out here like canceling people like like
if you were to you know take and say and
be like I'm pro-cancel culture like
you're a [__] loser so now it's like
yeah we all we're not on onboard cancel
culture anymore but the people who still
like want to cancel people they now call
it holding people accountable that's
like the new word when I see that I'm
like radar
um and so everyone's like we need to
hold Michaela accountable because she
lied but Kayla lied Bush died
people died so it's those people who are
like I'm just holding her accountable
and those are the same people who two
years ago were like I cannot believe
that you would use like a Jeffree Star
lip gloss like you know what he's done
so it's like they're so unscrupled like
it's just it's just whenever it's
popular are you gonna be like we're
holding Jeffrey accountable so it's like
we're now you you said you know Jeffree
Star said and did horrible things you'll
never support him but now Kayla maybe
wore a false lash and so you're gonna go
back that's this whole Saga has really
shown how [__] dumb people are and
I'm living for it yes so I like
Jeffrey's video he you know
Michaela he came for a little bit he
acknowledged like she's a new queen of
beauty and like people are coming for
your reviews and he did say like one
thing that I like struck a chord with me
it's like and the way that it feels like
Michaela if you want to wear a lash or
like you want to do a little like false
promo to sell more mascara like that's
fine and then maybe if you did lie about
it I want to get to the lie after but
like if she lied like she has only hurt
herself she has shot her credibility
because being a successful influencer
especially in the beauty space is all
about like people believe trusting you
so if you lie you are hurting yourself
in your business my new theory is that
she did not wear a false lash but that
she ended her video with a filter on
yeah to like make herself like look
pretty and by the way Tick-Tock filters
like the popular ones smoother skin and
add a lash right like even uh Instagram
filters like they add a lash and so that
like I did see the shadow that people
are talking about and I think it was a
filter so when she commented back I did
not wear a lash she wasn't lying she
wasn't lying but she enhanced her look
with a filter and like I know people
really don't like when people do Beauty
reviews yeah Beauty tic talkers use
filters with a filter and on principle I
totally get it but like there have been
so many times and I guess if you're
getting paid it's a little different but
like so many times I'll be like oh I
want to show this lipstick and like I'm
wearing a filter because like I'm human
and I want to look my best of course and
like you could still see what the
lipstick looks like no no I know it's a
little different when like you're
selling a mascara and the filter
literally has lashes it's like a little
too on the nose but I feel like in maybe
in her mind it's like okay I showed the
mascara how it works and now here's my
final look she wasn't wearing lashes the
whole time it was just in the final
frame so maybe it was like finished look
I'm a beauty queen I totally get what
you're saying it's really hard for me to
care you know what I mean I know but
once like I feel like a lot of people
feel this way it's like when I'm not in
this conversation I'm like Michaela did
or didn't yeah whatever the world goes
on when I start talking about it I'm
like well how many lashes did she wear
like people literally zooming in and
Counting the clothes if she just wore
one lash then maybe when she said I'm
not wearing last shoes it wasn't a lie
because it wasn't plural I like that so
she put on a strip it's just a one but
my new theory is filter I'm done I'm
feeling myself here's my final look you
finalize everything with a filter and
she just didn't
think that it would go as viral as it
did I mean the video is at like 50
million views she has still not
responded I just wanted to update you I
really never obsessed with the whole
thing I'm so curious I love this for her
I love this for L'Oreal I don't know how
it ends I hope I hope also I hope she's
okay because she's gone through like a
lot of she has a lot of lash recently no
and she's been very vocal she's like a
lot of mental health problems she's like
had depression since she was 16. I do
feel like
um
like the possibility of her like not
being okay is like very real I don't
think she's someone who handles this
stuff well and
it's a little scary to think about like
you I saw a video of her crying because
she was going to try on wedding dresses
you know it was like a very um like like
everyday normal thing that like centered
yeah that like she was hysterically
crying and she has body image issues and
she was explaining why
if you're so fragile yeah uh you know on
a day such as that like to hear the ire
of the entire internet like millions of
people calling you a liar Never Gonna
I'm just saying you guys like seriously
stop because it's just like one of these
people is not going to be able to handle
it no by the way I completely agree like
the way the internet just ascends and
like people feel so valid they're like
we're allowed to um criticize her like
we gave her this platform she's buying
her wedding dress with money we gave her
like people feel so entitled and like
feel such ownership of you that I do
feel like we are not far away from like
the internet taking it too far one of
these times yes people are not okay no
and like not everyone especially like
when someone is an influencer they
typically turn to the internet because
like they might have social anxiety they
might be shy like especially when in the
early days of the internet like people
who were went online were because like
real world wasn't like they were having
a hard time connecting with people and
so they they found like-minded people on
the internet and like it still doesn't
change who you are it's like maybe an
introverted person who's like not going
to be able to handle this stuff well no
but also what's so interesting
especially with people who get famous on
Tick Tock is it happens so fast and I
think with other influencers like they
go at it for years and years and they
have time to like build this exterior
where it's like with Michaela are you
experience things on a small scale which
is right next time you uh you have like
you know how to handle it yeah and then
they get bigger and bigger but you're
getting stronger and stronger yeah but
with Tick Tock like this overnight
success like I think Remy Bader is a
great example Michaela like overnight
like getting a million followers and
having no time to prepare it's not
anything like a normal human being can
handle no even like uh it's someone
who's been in the game for so long still
struggles they're like there are so many
like things that say like people human
beings like if you think back like
this was in the social delay yes if you
think back like hundreds of years like
the way that the internet happened has
been in such a short time frame and like
the human brain was never meant to
process more than like a handful of
people's opinions about you um
so this is very unnatural yeah so I just
think like everyone needs to calm down
like that's that's always my message
yeah so it wasn't a lash and also
Jeffree Star is a new boyfriend no one
has figured out there are no leads like
I don't think the internet always figure
something out Jeffrey's like actually
giving us nothing like this could be
like an actual actor yeah it could be
maybe like the pilot on the plane wants
to speak out right or the flight
attendant no we know nothing
we know nothing but I'm happy Jeffrey's
back because
I love a little Jeffrey in my life I do
too like there was a time when I was so
obsessed with him so obsessed I'm not
anymore but I do feel like because he
doesn't give anything to like yeah but
even towards the end like when he was
like doing more Shane Dawson stuff I was
like I was over it like the way that we
I can't believe I own that [__]
palette like which one conspiracy yeah
of course like I bought makeup from
Shane Dawson literally why
literally why make it make sense no the
way that I think phenomenon had this
culture in a [__] chocolate would say
to me like Jack so you're so mentally
strong that you could never like join a
cult or like be that I bought makeup
from Shane Dawson right no literally
literally it's like embarrassing well
you know what's even more embarrassing I
tried and I didn't even get it and then
I got a PR package with it and like I
tried and failed yeah I guess no but
like I actually still have a couple
Jeffree Star palettes like the orgy one
is very good
um I think he's like a good voice in The
Beauty Community we it was Jeffrey who
like who made us care we don't care
about Shane Dawson Jeffrey put his
Jeffree Star Sam no and like we knew
like it was like the theme of the
palette was Shane which I why
um
the theme of the palette was Shane but
like the company and the aesthetic and
everything was all Jeffrey that's why we
bought like we watched the stock new
series of like Shane getting into makeup
which like he had never once worn makeup
ever once cared about makeup like why
why no I don't know like it was actually
it was the power of influencers
wait Claudia like I remember when it
came out we were like in LA that week
and like the way we had to download the
episode for the plane oh is that what
happened like the last episode the last
episode I remember like I binge watched
him on the flight there and then on the
way home like the last one was coming
out like and we just would not have been
okay if we couldn't watch that's so much
and making makeup
it's really about Jeffrey though like
Jeffrey so he has to do like a year
where we were obsessed with Jeffrey but
like that's
that's how the internet was so weird
just a fun fact about us you know like
we about like a lot of us yeah no we
were all obsessed by the way it wasn't
just me and Jack no no we not at all we
were honestly a little late to the
bandwagon yeah we were I mean we wish I
was down and like we were all freaking
wait remember when the palette came out
and then there was a video that showed a
color that didn't make the cut that's
green and then they were going to
release another palette with just adding
the green yeah and we would have bought
that for the green a color I've never
worn no and honestly in my whole life
the way you're describing it is like
something I would have done when I was
actually 11 and when I tell you this was
two years ago no Blake
the way I'm describing it it's like is
if Kim and Kylie were yeah
I was I never was a Jeffree Star fan
before the series but like he's a
captivating figure but like yeah why am
I buying a Shane Dawson themed palette
no I have no idea
okay moving on before we get into
something to chew on for today more of
our shame spiral is brought to you by
Caraway new year new kitchenware with
Caraway start your year off right with
non-toxic kitchenware so you can ditch
the chemicals and make healthier cooking
a piece of cake with our exclusive
discount you can now save on the full
Suite of Caraway products including food
storage the tea kettle their mini
cookware it's the internet famous
cookware set and it is a staple for any
home and it comes in multiple colors and
it can fit with any design aesthetic
what colors do you have because I know I
have pink but I feel like you have a
different one I have like the cream one
oh yeah and it's so gorgeous it really
is I use it every single day for a
million different things like of course
for a chili for a soup I usually cook
eggs I use the pot like and then I also
I do use the bakeware
the pan nonstick it's amazing it is
um so they're non-toxic so they're made
without materials toxic materials like
pfas PTFE I can also cook Harry's food
in there right
um the Ceramics naturally slick surface
means that minimal oil or butter is
required for that slide off the pan eggs
and the easy cleaning it is so well
loved over 30 30 000 people have raved
about their Caraway kitchen and now it's
time to try it for yourself so visit
carawayhome.com toast10 to take
advantage of this limited time offer of
10 off your next purchase this deal is
exclusive for our listeners so visit
carawayhome.com
toast10 or use code toast10 at checkout
so Caraway again that code is
t-o-a-s-t-10 non-toxic cookware made
Modern today's episode is also brought
to you
by Perfect environment you were just
eating that chewing like an animal might
I add
um if you're looking for a protein bar
that actually tastes good look no
further than the perfect bar with their
lineup of fresh from the fridge protein
bars perfect bar is exactly what you've
been looking for with no chalky or
artificial aftertaste so uh perfect bar
is a great snack great thing to grab on
the go but what's great about it is that
it's so fresh that it has to be kept in
the fridge which I feel like all these
bars forever have been like we're fresh
and none of them have to be kept in the
fridge and now I'm like kind of looking
at all my other bars and being like you
guys are kind of gross you're being like
you're not fresh you're not fresh and
like how do you live with yourself
that's basically what I'm saying they're
made with freshly ground nut butter
organic honey and 20 organic superfoods
perfect bar has a variety of products
like protein bars and little snack size
bars that are also good and good for you
make sure to check out the dark
chocolate chip peanut butter with like a
little
a couple flecks of sea salt it's so good
um it's a great go-to snack and it'll
really keep you full for a decent amount
of time they're packed with up to six
grams of proteins and 150 calories so
those little snack ones go a long way
the texture of the bar is kind of not
like other bars it has like a cookie
dough texture and lob it's creamy and
full of flavor they're made with only
whole food ingredients and they contain
no artificial preservatives so they have
to be stored in the fridge perfect bar
knows that it'll be Love At First Bite
so for a limited time they're offering
you a chance to try their refrigerated
protein bars for free sign up for email
or text upload a picture of your receipt
from your local grocery store and they
will reimburse you for the cost of one
bar directly into your venmo or PayPal
all you have to do is go to perfect
snacks.com toast to get a free perfect
bar today that's perfect snacks.com
toast to get a free perfect bar today
happy snacking
our next story little casting news
Bridgerton Phoebe Denver says she's not
in Bridgerton season three she said
quote I did my two seasons well that's
making it sound a little nastier than it
is yeah but she recently told variety
about her Bridgerton future she said
well I did my two seasons I've done what
I wanted to do with the character and
she had a great Arc if they asked me
back in the future who knows uh she was
even more forthcoming to Screen Rant
saying that she's sadly not in season
three potentially in the future but
season three I'm just excited to watch
as a viewer honestly like after season
one the idea of her not being in season
two was like not even conceivable to me
and now like I really get how the show
works like you get so invested in the
next couple like we don't need Kate from
last season and her husband Phoebe's
brother we honestly don't need anyone
like they really like you get involved
and then you move on like you know they
live happily ever after yeah well we do
need the vi count because it's about the
brother it's about the brother yeah
um but I would just like
one since the Duke wasn't ever there
there's not like more they can really
build on with
um him and Phoebe but if I were Phoebe
like I would always want to come back to
the show and like be on the next season
just like hey guys I'm here still here
so popular it's so popular and like
she's doing other movies and shows but
it's like I would just always want to
like have my foot in it's probably not
that easy and maybe they were like okay
your time here is done like maybe it was
a mutual decision not her just leaving
but if it were me like I'd want to you
know get in there and be like yeah give
me five minutes brother let me help you
of course probably get married yeah of
course it's literally the number one
show in the world yeah so like that's
just me but I feel like you know with
these actors they're like oh no
constantly biting the hand that feeds
them they're like yeah my character
they always love that
um I'm really excited for the season
focusing on Penelope I feel like this
has to be like a culmination of sorts
because she is I know I'm kind of like
not excited because I think she's a
wench I know she was being really
[__] wenchy at the end of season two
and
I know everyone like ships hurt in Colin
but I think she's kind of toxic oh you
want my water like choking over here I
didn't make fun of you I just asked you
to move it off the table last sip ew
like backwash I feel like you know
backwasher so clean yeah no because I
don't put my whole mouth on it like that
Jesus [__] Christ just like that yep
oh God it's made it work
at work
um
so I'm kind of like not rooting for
Penelope I think Colin deserves someone
tabula rasa not someone who messed with
him all these years do you think that
they don't end up together like is that
a possibility I'm not rooting for it oh
wow just because like she's oh she's so
selfish she was being like a like a
whiny [__] and like she did all that
stuff with Marina like a few seasons
going I know like you love him but like
you're playing with people's lives yeah
yeah no she's like constantly wielding
her power like for evil yeah except like
Marina did end up in a good situation a
very good wouldn't have happened yeah
but still like it's not you you can't
play God you can't yeah she's kind of a
wench but like I do love her she's just
like like
she's just like sad yeah maybe she needs
some humbling yeah and I'm sure I'm sure
she'll get it yeah because also like
nose her friend knows and didn't they
lose their money
yes but she like has the starting
business right right she's like
literally like a local business owner
yeah which you do love to see like girl
boss girl like she definitely is on
SquarePants she's definitely girl
bossing a little too close to the Sun
that's the thing yeah
um so I'm excited for season three uh
like this makes no difference the
storyline but it's crazy because it's
like she is perjured him yeah
like she like wasn't even Bridgerton
last season like I don't think of her
anymore Phoebe as like the face of
richardton when when I found out she was
going to be in season two I was like am
I even gonna watch but now I understand
like we focus on a different couple
every season I don't care that she's not
gonna be in it yeah especially you're
right since her boyfriend isn't yeah
knowing he had such a bright future like
he left the show what the [__] is he
doing now he should be in season three
right
are you ready for our fifth and final
story final story yeah Wedding Bells for
Abigail Breslin I'm married I'm married
she married Iraq kunianski nearly one
year after their engagement is pretty
low-key she captured
Ira close-up photo of her diamond ring
saying y'all your girl got married y'all
and then no no no it was yeah girl got
married y'all confusing and then the
next day she posted like more photos
from the wedding and shared more but it
was like a real wedding she didn't just
like wake up one day and say I think
I'll get married today no it's like a
full affair with a party dress and
they're doing what looks to be the
horror was he Jewish or she Jewish
what was his last name
kunianski he could yeah
um like for me I know we've seen so many
different stages of Abigail breslin's
life she will always be Little Miss
Sunshine to me and like the fact that
Little Miss Sunshine is married is a
beautiful thing to me She'll always be
his Chanel Number Five I know that which
is so crazy because it was like a a blip
on the radar but I'm like oh okay so
were the other chanels there and were
they nice to her finally did she have
them as bridesmaids I am curious who are
her celebrity friends
well I feel like that article would have
mentioned like you know Emma Roberts
yeah but there's also not that much
content out yet to like maybe if Emma
was there like she just hasn't shared
from the wedding like Billy Lord I feel
like her and Billy Lord were friends
yeah maybe Leah Michelle right
so I don't know but I feel like she's
has like a star studded
group of friends I also feel like she's
like majorly pulled back from the
industry it's like maybe she doesn't
yeah yes and no I need to watch ultimate
Sunshine again it's been far too long
yeah are you okay your mic is falling
apart engagement engagement
um
okay well happy for her happy for us
getting through another amazing show
yeah changing lives
yeah so now that your life has changed I
hope that you can go on with your
amazing day thank you so much for
listening to the toast the millennial
Morning Show where we deliver the fast
five stories you need to know every
Monday through Friday on YouTube for
watching this on YouTube please
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up we're also available as a podcast and
we're podcasting we found so Spotify
agencies Republic video I already
castbox all the places where bills and
podcast find us the Joseph
setting and wickedly talented we are I
sound like a Cantor on you at schul
have a great day we'll see you tomorrow
love you bye
rice and Stripes
[Music]